welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
back to The Saga of George Santos the
New York Republican Congressman
repeatedly lied about his background and
resume while he's now announced he is
temporarily anyway stepping down from
his house committee assignments while he
is under Federal and local investigation
into his personal and campaign finances
however Santos is still resisting calls
from most of his own constituents to
resign Caitlin Huey Burns again has more
from Capitol Hill
under intense legal scrutiny
representative Santos recused himself
from his new committee assignments
apologizing to his Republican colleagues
for being a distraction and pledging to
clear his name why are you confident
he'll be clear we have nothing to hide
why do you think you're under
investigation
with a narrow House Majority speaker
Kevin McCarthy said he believes Santos
would eventually serve on the Committees
the voters have elected him he'll have a
voice here in Congress until he answers
all those questions then he'll at that
time he'll be able to be seated
Santos has lied about his education work
history Heritage and even his mother
being in the towers on 9 11.
you got to relax
back in his district his support is
dwindling a new poll shows 78 percent of
Voters there say their Congressman
should resign including 71 percent of
Republicans I don't think lying is
excusable ever
period but Santos says he isn't giving
up his seat I've said I was sorry many
times I've behaved as if I'm sorry I can
guarantee you that from now on anything
and everything is always going to be
above board it's largely always been
above board I'm just gonna go the extra
step now to double check cross-reference
everything for two of Santos's fellow
New York Republican lawmakers that's not
enough they want him to leave Congress
all together and they say the recusal is
a case of someone quitting right before
they were going to get fired for CBS
mornings Caitlin Huey Burns in
Washington
I'm not
I I don't understand he he's always said
that if the people in his district want
him out now you have polls that say 78
percent say bye-bye George and he's
still staying
I Marvel at this story Mr Santos please
speak to our David beg now I think
that's an interview we all want to see
I'd like to sit down and speak with him
so the invitation is open